foreign
this is the dominant side of that form
so as I come in here we come to show
energy position I'm able to drive into
it but I find here that I can't quite
take him over so he wants to drop his
elbow or something because the Eco is
not available anymore I Circle this hand
and push his elbow down as he comes down
he's naturally going to want to raise
his elbow to stop the pain in his wrist
as he does that I push his elbow over
and drive my inside knee down from this
position I have a lot of Leverage into
his shoulder so I'm going to drop my
knee in which is causing a lot of pain
in the shoulder as I do this I'm going
to hook my arm across
so as I drop my knee across this hand's
hooking I want to hook this way that way
his arm were to fall it's getting caught
right in the crook of my arm here I grab
my D for stability this hand's now free
so I can be drawing a weapon using a
weaponry and striking him with it but
instead for the form I'm just going to
cut to the Elbow drive your shoulders
straight down up and over
one more time to speak
I I
show Medusa